Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
just checkin in object.
Just fucking cough,
man.
I don't know what's going on,
dude.
There's something going.
Wow.
I heard about it,
dude.
You'd hear that about that guy in swamp Scott already fucking dude.
The fucking guy die.
He had to fucking sniffles.
You went up,
dude.
He went upstairs to bed and it came up in that no fucking guy was dead.
There's always those stories around Europe,
uh,
around Europe,
about a brown winter this time of year,
right?
Europe.
I'm thinking about my year old dates.
I might as well tell you,
listen to this shit.
The following cities in Europe from my European tour and have sold out Munich
often buck ragga or Riga,
Vienna,
Liverpool,
London,
Copenhagen and Helsinki.
A second show will be added at the Royal Albert Hall in London.
More shows in other cities of second shows.
If we feel that we can sell them,
uh,
they will be,
they will be added.
All right.
They go.
Okay.
And the Patrice O'neil comedy benefit.
February 19th,
2019 Jim Gaffigan,
uh,
fucking rich Vos,
myself and a bunch of other people.
I don't have the shit in front of me.
A big Jay Oakerson and little bill birth.
We're all going to be down there.
It's going to be tremendous.
Um,
alright.
Plowing ahead here.
Um,
yeah,
I don't know everybody,
my fucking house is sick right now and I got to go to a New York because I'm
doing a benefit on December 1st in the city.
I tweeted about it and I forget what the fuck it's going to be at,
but um,
she'll be a good time,
music and a comedy extravaganza to help people with,
I dunno what I did,
but I never fucking know.
They just ask and I say,
all right,
I'll do it.
Then you make the bad mistake as a comedian is you don't find out what the
benefits for before you go on stage and then you end up doing a fucking joke
about it.
What is this?
Is this a benefit but cancer?
Yes,
it is.
Oh,
sorry.
Sorry.
I should have looked in.
I should have looked in before I fucking,
you know,
for,
I started doing my shit.
I apologize.
Um,
so,
you know,
it's funny,
my,
uh,
one of my relatives ask me what's on your Christmas list.
I should have talked to him about this speaker thing I should ask Joe.
Rosa was just here,
we were taping an uninformed,
I should have asked him what exactly it is that I need,
like where the problem is.
Cause right now I just hold it,
you know,
like a fucking suicide bomber if we got take like your thumb off the thing and
then you blow up.
That's the way I got to hold it to be able to hear shit and uh,
I think it's going to affect my performance.
Um,
so anyways,
I was sleeping
so soundly.
Yeah.
All right.
I went to bed early,
I ate great.
I had no booze,
none of that bullshit.
I fucking just went to sleep and I was sleeping so soundly and I am awoken to
this noise that sounds like literally like God's alarm clock.
It was just going,
Eh,
and
right.
So I'm like,
the fuck is that right?
Yay.
And I opened the window,
you know,
I go over,
I'm going to open up the window.
Okay.
Yay.
I'm like,
it's fucking outside.
So I go outside.
Yay.
Fucking,
I don't know what at the power box,
the pallet box,
whatever the side of my house where it says,
you know,
high voltage and all of that shit.
I just walk up to it and it's just like,
Yay.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
And then right as I walked up to it,
it just stopped nay.
And I went inside and you know,
nothing has happened since.
So I'm going to go out on a limb and I want to say that somebody should take a
look at that thing.
It was raining on.
I don't what happened.
I heard sirens down the street.
Somebody probably slammed into a fucking pole.
Yeah.
Or something.
I don't,
I don't know.
I don't cause last name,
but we know before I went to bed,
you know,
I was driving home from the comedy store and uh,
I saw like fucking three fire trucks down the street.
And,
uh,
I made a left before it got to him and shit.
And I dunno,
you know,
it rains a little bit out here and people just fucking slamming the trees
because it never rains out here.
So all the oil and antifreeze and fucking just shit,
it's just on the road and all it takes is a little bit of water and it gets
slick as hell and a plus.
People aren't used to driving and then I guess,
and they just fucking crash the cars.
So anyways,
okay.
Evidently I stared down this electricity and it got self conscious and it
stopped making the fucking noise and then I get my house and then,
you know,
it's the first rain of the year,
so I got to go up on my roof and make sure there's no fucking problems,
you know.
And one of the gutters was clogged up just because,
you know,
we've got trees out here and shit falls in there and when it rains it pours out.
It just like the song.
So I'm fucking cleaning out the Goddamn gutters and uh,
I almost fucking fell off the roof.
There's a,
it's split second.
You know,
cause I didn't want to get wet so I was crouched down.
I wasn't leaning back,
I was just sorta crouched down and I was reaching forward and it was just like,
what the fuck am I doing?
I had to do that quick math like bill,
what would you rather do?
Would you rather get your clothes wet and have to throw them in the hamper or
would you like to die or be paralyzed?
So I laid down on the roof,
you know,
and it fucking cleaned all this shit out.
Cause that's what I do.
That's the thankless fucking work you do as a dad and nobody appreciates it.
You know,
you make sure the water gets away from the foundation,
you know,
you do those types of things for,
I don't know the roof over the your fucking head.
No,
maybe I'm just spoiled.
You know,
cause I tell a joke and everybody laughs,
you know,
you guys give me an Atta boy every fucking 10 to 12 seconds,
so whatever,
eight to 10 of them killing.
Um,
maybe that's what the fuck it is.
But now,
now I have to get some goddamn electrician to come over and figuring out what
the fuck that thing is about.
My front door lock is fucked up.
It's just like,
it's just never ending.
You know?
I don't know who the fuck the American dream was.
You wanted to own a house,
but I swear to God,
it's just,
it's never fucking ending plus,
but there's another way to do it.
There's other people,
they just live in a house and when something breaks,
they just deal with it.
You know,
those kinds of people,
they buy a car and they don't get it fixed ever.
They don't get the fucking,
you know,
remember back in the day they'd have those sports cars with the lights flip down
and flipped up and one would just be up and they would just drive around and be
okay with it.
You know?
I always set that,
that was like a,
like a,
a ridiculous like sign of a loser.
Like this guy's a fucking loser.
I know he's got a core of it,
but like he's,
he's,
he's living beyond his fucking means.
You know how unless it just happened.
How long are you going to ride around with that fucking thing?
Looking up like that,
the beautiful lines of that car and you're fucking it up with that and just,
I would watch people that drive me nuts.
Your parents are always like that.
If something broke in the car,
they just fucking,
they ain't never got it fixed.
I don't get that
pill.
You really mad about this?
I don't think so.
It's just I was sleeping soundly and then yeah,
like my daughter was still asleep at fucking woke her up and it's just like,
it can,
it can.
I just have one fucking day where I,
I get,
I mean I feel like I get eight hours,
so,
oh,
was I sleeping well?
I was sleeping so good.
Oh God.
It was so fucking great.
And then I just woke up.
I was like,
what the fuck is said?
What the fuck is why?
What is that?
Is that what the alarm in the house sounds like?
Is there a serial killer in the house?
Can you give me another five minutes to sleeping?
Let,
shouldn't we just fucking laying there in bed.
You just don't give a shit.
Um,
I vaguely remember my Nia coming into waking me up last night as your wife does,
you know,
you sleeping soundly.
Why when they wake up she goes,
was that the car?
Was that the house alarm?
Did you hear that?
And I went,
no.
And I did hear it.
It's just like I'm not fucking going downstairs for the 9000000th time with that
softball bat going down the fucking stairs just to find out that the the fucking
window in our old ass house,
you know,
blew open a little bit.
Um,
then I woke up feeling guilty like I should have done it,
but I was just sleep.
I was sleeping so fucking,
well.
Anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
So freckles,
um,
I mentioned,
yeah,
I my uh,
on the Monday morning podcast I was going to be on the Joe Rogan experience.
Uh,
there ended up being a little confusion on the booking.
So instead it's going to be December 20th.
And,
uh,
which you'll be cool because I'm going to hang with Joe a couple times before
that.
It give us some tea,
some shit to talk about.
Cause I hadn't seen him in a while just cause I've been doing the road and he's
been doing his stuff.
So,
uh,
that got rescheduled and um,
I also said I was doing dice Clay's podcast.
I wasn't,
it was somebody else's pocket.
I fucked the whole thing up.
But I did call in spit and chiclets on Barstool so I did,
I did do that.
Right.
And I also said thatF is for family was coming out today and it is,
and it's coming out tomorrow,
the 30th.
So I basically,
I fucked everything up.
Um,
I apologize.
So,
um,
anyways,
okay.
Hang on a second.
What the fuck is that now?
Yeah.
Anyways,
next week I am going to be on a,
I'm going to be on Seth Meyers show on Tuesday of next week promotingF is for
family.
And then I will also be,
uh,
at the Gotham comedy club doing a show with Paul Versey and Sam j.
It's going to be awesome.
Christmas in New York and we suck.
They all suck cause I'm with my family and shit.
But a big bang,
boom real quick.
Oh,
and then right back and uh,
uh,
back on the Diet.
I'm not boozing,
it had been dry for five days,
bored out of my mind,
but obviously sleeping well until my fucking side of my house starts buzzing.
But I've decided that I've lied to get in great shape again.
Like I did the end of August and then Labor Day came and I made a couple of
Burgers,
had a couple of beers and I just,
then I had six weeks on the road and I just,
I fucking put it,
almost all of it back on.
But now I've turned the ship around and all freckles is headed back.
Last time I was able to get four ABS,
four out of Eight,
I got halfway there.
You know,
you don't really feel like you ever watched the,
uh,
American Ninja Warrior and there's that fucking guy every year.
Hey,
last year he couldn't get past the fucking trap piece and then he gets past the
trap.
He's,
he's all excited.
Then he does a face plant on the next [inaudible] fucking
whatever you call it,
object,
obstacle,
whatever.
The fuck you call it that.
That's basically what I'm doing is far as trying to get in shape,
but a,
at least this time,
cause I went to nutritionalists a nutritionist,
I know how to a,
I know how to eat.
So I've just been doing that and it got to me,
once you lay off the booze,
it's fucking,
it's all good.
It's all good.
So I go home and my new show on me TV,
I watched the untouchables and as an episode of,
uh,
I watched the other day,
he had a young Carroll O'connor who played Archie bunker,
Ron.
And it's just the,
uh,
it really is the shit.
And um,
you know,
I got my Christmas tree already fucking amazing already got my Christmas tree.
I was sitting there going,
you know what?
I want to get a good one this year.
I'm going to knock that out before I go to New York.
I'll just make sure,
you know,
my wife waters the fucking thing.
And uh,
so I go down there and it's just classic La,
why I love La and why it can be annoying.
Sometimes I show up to buy a Christmas tree and there's some like,
you know,
fucking hot chick,
right?
This Asian chick just dressed ridiculously nice bike.
She was going to go walk a red carpet,
you know,
high heels,
makeup,
the whole fucking thing.
Getting out of this shiny SUV.
I'm like,
what the fuck are you buying a Christmas tree like that?
Then of course I look over the left and there's a guy with the fucking camera
filming or there's some fucking reality show.
I mean like full makeup,
the whole,
you think reality shows look fucking stupid when you watch them at home.
If you see one that's really being shot,
it's just like,
what the fuck?
Who the fuck looks like that going to get a God damn Christmas tree?
MMM.
Yeah.
And I'm standing there and I'm trying to find what I'm facetiming with my wife.
What about this white [inaudible] care full enough,
you know,
go through all that bullshit.
Then all of a sudden this other guy shows up.
He's dressed like little Bo peep,
swear to God,
but with like a beard and everything.
This guy,
mini skirt,
tattoos on his legs and holding a selfie stick,
filming himself with full fucking makeup on.
And I was just like,
all right,
you know,
this is uh,
this is fucking la man.
Will this cough ever go away?
I think I might take some medicine.
My wife had me go on and get some Robitussin.
I've always been a Nyquil guy,
you know?
Well I gotta tell you I cannot taste the fucking difference between the two of
them.
They get that red shit.
It's almost like you'd rather die in pneumonia than fucking drink that stuff.
And now when you go there to buy it,
they actually asked for your fucking id,
which is really annoying.
It's like,
look at me lady.
Do you think I'm fucking,
do you really think I'm 20 look at me and I hand the gang.
He think gag a death.
You know,
you mentioned like,
that's like how rock bottom.
You know how much fucking going to look that up.
I don't know how to spell Robitussin,
but I am a drink.
Look up Nyquil.
This shit that I end up looking up on my fucking laptop because of this God damn
podcast.
I can't imagine what.
So watch lunch list.
I'm on here.
How much is that Nyquil?
The window.
NYQUIL.
Okay.
To get drunk
right now.
They're all thinking this is a functioning alcoholic because he's drinking
Nyquil to get shit faced yet.
He's still somehow is.
It has access to a laptop and the Internet.
All right.
Drinking copious amounts of Nyquil.
Pros,
a bottle comes with its own personal shotglass.
All right,
already love this right here.
Yeah,
I already loved this.
Sorry.
What do we got here?
Alright.
Flood Cat tampons.
What the fuck?
What,
what part of the Internet of my aunt
vapor teeny vodka.
Eyeballing and snorting.
Do these people are fucking crazy people.
Don't do any of this,
but let's,
let's listen to it for the comedy taking shots of mouthwash wine.
Ice Cream.
All right,
I can do that.
Oh,
at copious amounts of Nyquil.
All right.
Pro.
Okay.
Nyquil,
this nighttime sniffling,
sneezing,
coughing.
How the fuck did I end up on the kitchen floor?
Medicine.
Okay.
Uh,
but this is on a spoon.
university.com by the way,
a bottle comes with its own personal shot glass.
This is the pros.
Take a few shots,
fight the sleepy feeling,
and then you're in for a hazy,
loopy drunk slash high combination.
It's kind of weird that you got to like fucking fight off going asleep.
All right.
Cons,
you have to be 18 to buy it and most drug stores,
which is a big deterrent for the under age population of binge drinkers.
Not a reliable way to get drunk.
You might just send up passed out or worse sober.
Yeah.
People don't do any of this,
especially if you're fucking underage,
but I for the comedy,
I have to read this here.
Okay.
All right.
Tired of the wretched taste of booze.
This is this how they set this up like no booze tastes worse.
Busch light doesn't taste worse than Nyquil.
Simply drinking alcohol to get drunk these days is just so mainstream in the
mood to potentially,
they'll probably just making fun of,
okay,
they're making,
I get it.
They're being sarcastic here so it's not Reggie taste of booze.
Then making fun of how rich and all this other shit is.
Okay?
I'm in the mood to potentially take a trip to the er or meet hot doctors.
Check out these alternative methods of imbuing for hardcore alcoholics only.
Not for the faint of heart.
Disclaimer,
in case she didn't get it.
Do not try any of these messages.
Methods.
Seriously,
don't.
Yeah,
This is what lunatics do.
Vodka tampons.
All right?
A good friend shows you how to soak your Tampon in vodka for a quicker buzz.
These are like little advertisements like this is smart things to do,
which it isn't.
I have to keep putting that disclaimer out there before when you dopes does this
do not do this pros,
these suckers were designed for more than just that time of the month and
nosebleeds.
Soak one up with your choice of liquor.
Um,
who am I kidding?
If you're trying this method,
you're most definitely a vodka gal.
They're supposed to hold a show about a shot's worth.
Shove it up there to bypass your digestive track and get drunk way faster.
It doesn't,
it sting.
Okay.
Cons,
a yard.
Golf.
You only got one.
You only get one vagina.
Flooding the sensitive area with 40 proof liquor is bound to leave a wake of
destruction.
Your baby coming out drunk would be the least of your problems.
Ladies,
stick to fake tampon flasks.
They sell it.
I don't know what the fuck.
Okay.
That was too many jokes here.
What's a vapor?
Teeny.
No calories,
no carbs,
no hangover.
Smooth taste and feel the effects of liquor much quicker.
Since the alcohol bypasses your stomach,
he could also bypass your liver so that those with liver damage from too much
drinking can once again partake.
This doesn't make sense.
Also,
you look like a boss smoking alcohol out of an orb with a metal straw.
Oh,
that's like that.
Chemistry Shit.
Vodka.
Eyeball snorting,
eyeballing and snorting.
All right.
This is just dumb shit.
All right,
I'm done with it.
Okay.
I'm done.
I can't believe anybody would ever fucking do that.
Pour alcohol into your fucking eye.
That can't be right.
Can I just do the reeds here?
People just,
you know,
I was in such a holiday fucking boot,
a tipsy elves.
Uh,
everyone needs an ugly Christmas sweater this time of year at deck the halls
with one of a tipsy elves,
outrageous Christmas sweater designs.
They're one of a kind,
seriously high quality and crazy comfortable too.
These aren't the sweaters your GAM GAM used to make,
supposed to be Grand Graham.
They're insanely funny and unbelievably well made specific sizing for men and
women.
So everyone gets the perfect fit for men.
Stylish suits for the classiest of holiday gentlemen,
interactive sweaters,
beer pong,
corn hole,
drinking game darts.
So uncle Bob can relieve,
relive his college glory days at a fun family dying at dinner.
Sorry,
a man even hilarious themes,
teas and awesome cozy onesies for women holiday dresses so you can get down with
your bad self.
Oh Jesus,
I catching leggings so you can strike a festive yoga pose or lounge around with
a cup of spiked eggnog and tease that sleigh and cute,
comfy onesies.
Oh,
tease that sleigh and cute,
comfy onesies.
You won't find more hilarious,
awesome designs anywhere else.
So be sure to order from tipsy elves and time for your ugly Christmas sweater
party.
And Right now my listeners get 20% off tipsy elves.com t I p s y e l v e s.com.
When you use my code [inaudible] at checkout B,
you are our go to tipsy elves.com and enter my code bar at checkout to get your
20% sitewide discount.
Oh,
and look who's,
yeah.
Nobody wants to feel like they're overpaying while shopping online,
but did you know that there's an easy way to always get the lowest price?
It's called hi
honey is a free shopping tool that automatically saves you money by searching
the Internet for the best promo codes.
Whenever you shop online.
That means you get the best deals without even trying on your favorite trying on
your favorite sites like Amazon,
Ebay,
Walmart,
best buy,
new egg,
Etsy,
Groupon,
and more.
Uh,
in fact,
honey,
oh honey has already saved listeners of this podcast and average of $46 and 8
cents.
Honey does it all for you.
It also applies the biggest discount,
right at checkout.
Honey has over 10 million members and over 100,005 star reviews.
There's no reason not to add [inaudible] dot com slash bar dot.
There's no reason to not add honey to your browser today.
Get honey today for free@joinhoney.com slash burr that's two words.
Join honey.com/burr honey.
The easiest way to save money while shopping online.
All right,
two more.
Everybody hang in there.
Hymns.
Do you want your hairline to recede or do you want to do something about it
first?
Why did guys turned a weird solutions or do nothing?
I don't know cause you don't have the fight and yet anymore.
Um,
when they could turn to medicine and science for hymns.com a one stop shop for
hair loss.
Skincare,
sexual wellness for men.
Look at this thing.
Get your hair.
Go and get your dick standing up.
A solution.
The tropes thanks to sides.
Baldness can be optional.
That's awesome.
He ums,
connects with real doctors and medical grade solutions to treat hair loss,
well known generic equivalents to name brand prescriptions to help you keep your
hair.
No snake oil pills or gas station counter supplements.
Prescription solutions backed by science.
No waiting room,
no awkward in person,
doctor visit.
Save hours by going to,
for hymns.com so easy answer.
A few quick questions.
Doctor will review and can prescribe.
Your products are shipped directly to your door.
Eventually I'm going to,
I am going to do this.
I'm going to get my hair back when I'm like 85 when they,
then they got like some just ridiculously perfect,
you know,
method,
and then I'll die like a day later and some will have to brush my hair before
they cremate me.
Uh,
my listeners to get a trial month of hymns for just $5 right now while supplies
last.
See websites for full details.
This wonderful costs.
Uh,
this would cost hundreds if you went to the doctor or a pharmacy,
go to free him.
[inaudible] dot com slash bird that's f o r a h I m s.com/burr for him,
for him [inaudible] dot com slash burr.
And lastly,
but not leastly jolly shave club.
Dude,
I don't know why I read that.
Like,
uh,
that guy,
Monster Mash Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to look,
feel and smell your best and never,
and you never have to go to the stores.
Uh,
that's because they deliver everything you need right to your door and they keep
you fully stocked on what you use so you don't run out.
Here's how it works.
Dollar Shave Club has everything you need to get ready no matter what you're,
you,
you're getting ready for,
they have you covered head to toe for your hair,
your skin,
your face.
You okay.
You name it.
Uh,
they have it and they have this new okay program.
The only reason why I know that references cause the Nia and um,
and they have,
yeah,
this new program where they automatically keep you stocked up on the products
you use.
You determine what you want and when you want it.
And it shows up right at your door for once a month,
uh,
to once every six months plus with their handsome discount.
The more you buy,
the more you save.
And Right now dollar shave club has a bunch of status sets.
Uh,
you can try for just $5,
like their oral care kit after that,
the restock box ships regular size products at regular price.
Uh,
get you status set,
but just $5 right now@dollarshaveclub.com slash burr B u.
R.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar.
We asked you guys a question,
have you,
you haven't have you guys anybody out there?
Um,
okay.
Ever have a friend of yours that was just fucking Kojak bald like me.
And then out of nowhere they came back with a full head of hair.
How fucking weird is that?
Okay.
That's gotta be weird.
And I gotta tell you right now,
if you never,
if you,
if you don't have a friend that did it,
you're going to have one in me because I consider you guys friends.
I'm going to fucking do it,
man.
Okay?
I'm going to get some astro turf glued to the top of my head.
Let me see this completely bald.
MMM.
Hair recce duration.
Oh God.
I'm going,
you want me to fucking ads?
I'm going to get the sidebar.
I'll give a fuck.
Why don't the hair restoring that did it?
Eh.
Okay.
Entire hair plants,
surgeries,
hair transplant,
surgery.
Can a bald person receive a hair transplant?
This is Bosley.
Obviously they're going to say yes.
They want your fucking money.
Oh,
why don't you just go to images?
Images.
Okay.
That guy was not completely bald.
This guy was really bald and now he's got the Conor Mcgregor.
These guys,
they just always look,
ah,
that guy looks good.
It always looks just a little weird.
Okay,
well guys have good heads.
I
don't know why he just wouldn't fucking shaved the goddamn thing.
Fuck it.
Right?
Oh,
that's that tattoo that people get on top of you head to keep your hair buzz
down.
Nope.
They still don't have it down.
They still just don't have it.
Wow.
There are a lot of famous people.
Oh my God.
What the fuck happened to that guy?
Hair transplant gone wrong.
Jesus Christ.
Look,
St Pete took a,
it took a fucking hatchet to his head.
Nah,
that's bullshit.
That can't be real.
You know people.
Why do,
why do people feel the need to lie so much on the Internet?
Have you ever wondered that?
That's something hair transplants gone wrong.
I have discussed hair trans,
I'm not reading.
Fuck year is this hair trance.
Plant law suits.
There we go.
Boom.
Images.
Oh Jesus.
Let's see what we got here.
Hatchet head.
They got old hatch.
Hatchet had keeps coming up.
Yeah.
And there's a lot of people let us celebrities were starting to go.
You saw Brian Urlacher did it by north lack of look great bald.
Oh Jesus.
Look at that
bad hair plugs.
Yeah.
Dude,
this is the,
can I tell you some,
every time I think about doing this shit,
I look at these pictures and like,
I'm not fucking doing that.
Oh my God.
Look at these fucking Jack Atlanta looking sons of bitches.
Oh,
there's a good one.
That guy.
Yeah,
this guy got a good one.
I got it though.
I guess really listening to me googling the shit.
What the fuck am I doing?
Can we get back to the goddamn shell?
Um,
anyways.
you don't need as people.
I did fucking back to back episodes of uninformed with Joe de Rosa and I am
fucking,
I'm for the one of the few times in my life,
I'm a little talked out.
I am,
I'm just a little fucking talked out and I'm fucking stab and,
and I want to go get something to eat,
but my wife is fucking pissed at me right now cause I flipped out about
something really important,
you know,
like,
uh,
I don't know what the fuck I feel.
I didn't know what the fuck.
I just want to see us,
what I was right.
And then I flipped out and then I became wrong as always,
you know,
then I tried to walk away and then she wants to fucking,
let's just sit down and discuss it like fucking a regular person.
I'm just like,
I'm not a regular person and I'm already heated.
So you gotta let me walk away.
You know,
she won't let me walk away.
it's got to get out of the way.
What highlight,
Huh?
Tommy Lasorda,
New York Yankees.
Reggie Jackson leaning into that ball accidentally according to him.
Um,
anyways,
I,
uh,
she says I'm always in the fucking dog house.
Anyways,
I want to thank everybody for listening today.
Uh,
thank you to everybody who's been buying the Patrice O'Neal tickets.
they're going even faster than usual every year.
They go by fast for the benefit.
Thank you for that.
And thank you to everyone that's joining my patrion page.
Uh,
we have all the backstage footage of,
um,
my arena shows at the forum,
the Boston Garden and Madison Square Garden.
W me walking off Madison Square Garden is,
uh,
arguably the coolest moment of my life.
Not the most important.
I had a kid get married and shit,
but like the coolest moment of my fucking life because the show could not have
gone better.
And I talked to the audio guide today and we got the audio.
There's no problem.
And,
uh,
I'm hoping to be releasing that in vinyl after my next special cause there'll be
too much overlap in the material.
But,
um,
uh,
I'm,
I'm very anxious to hear the audio cause it's like,
dude,
I want people when they listened to it to feel like they're at the fucking show
and I'm not going to lie to you.
It was a good one.
So,
um,
that is it.
Um,
enjoy the music here and uh,
we'll have another half hour bonus material from my Thursday afternoon just
before Friday,
Monday morning podcast with Thursday.
God,
by years and years ago or I don't know,
a couple of weeks ago.
I don't know how it works.
All right,
I'll see you guys.
Many guys had come to you with a line and you pay down
and bare lines.
Let me try.
No,
I don't.
So anyways,
uh,
well yeah,
we got to go it
Christmas tree.
So for the last two years
I have to admit something to you people.
All right.
I have been going down to get these fucking Christmas trees and I have been
getting the traditional Christmas tree and we all know what it looks like.
All right.
It looks like someone on the biggest loser about four weeks in.
That's what a Christmas tree suppose about that full,
you know,
but disease,
other Christmas trees that I noticed,
not the scrawny ones,
but they are minimalists Christmas trees where you can see the entire trunk and
it's like they still have the branches,
but there it's very like symmetrical.
It looks fucking cool as hell.
Clean looking Christmas tree,
right.
It looks like one of those trees and like the doctor Seuss books,
you know.
So I go,
you know what?
Fuck this.
I'm going to get something different.
I liked this tree.
It looks fucking cool.
I think the ornaments are going to hang off it much better as if you don't,
when you get one of those full trees,
you know this.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's a fucking pain in the ass.
And then the end of the end of the God damn,
you know,
Christmas season,
if you're not a dick and you just don't throw it out the side of your car,
like a fucking some,
you know,
some piece of degenerate gambler that owed him money.
I said have it by Tuesday and then you just throw it out the fucking right.
If you actually do it the right way and you,
you saw it up,
it's a pain in the ass.
It makes an unbelievable mess.
This thing,
you know,
it's like,
it's like you ever walk into like,
uh,
like when I'm out with,
with a,
with Nia and we go out to one of her,
uh,
her clothing stores and um,
if it's like a corporate place,
the place is just jam packed was shit.
But if it's like a privately owned,
they go out and they buy these individual pieces still by a couple of sizes of
each things that they like.
And you go in there,
you pray to God that they have your size and it's,
and you go in and it's very minimalist.
That's the sort of Christmas tree that I bought.
And uh,
you know,
knee is a fashion Easter so I thought she would like it.
So I bring this Christmas tree in and the second she looks at it,
cause I think she's going to be like,
you know,
like I live at,
she just have like techno music on like I'm so far into the fucking future here.
The second sheet looks at it all my confidence just drains out the bottom of my
shoes and I go,
yeah,
this is the Christmas tree.
And she goes,
Oh yeah.
He goes,
where's the rest of it?
And I'm like,
no,
no.
That's the style.
That's the style it's supposed to look like that.
I go,
it doesn't have the cool,
I mean it looks like one of those trees and Dr Seuss.
She goes,
yeah.
I think it looks more like that,
that Christmas tree and that Charlie Brown carts,
and I feel like an asshole.
So because I love the verbal abuse that you guys give me every fucking week.
I'm actually going to be dumb enough to send a picture of my Christmas tree.
Now granted it's naked.
It's not all dressed up.
It's not all dolled up.
All right.
It's like Charlie's Thoren and that stupid movie monster that rather than
chastising her for being a murderous cont,
they actually made a movie that said maybe guys Outta look at themselves and
treat bitches a little bit better before they go and start killing you after a
blow job.
It wasn't that the message in the move SMS,
which I got.
So anyways,
it doesn't have any makeup on,
which I think should automatically give it a golden globe for being that
courageous.
It was so brave.
It was such a brave performance.
Um,
just take a look at the Christmas tree.
Tell me what you think.
I think it looks fucking bad ass.
I love it.
I fucking love it.
And uh,
I stand by it.
You know,
I'm breaking a little tradition.
Here
are no
ahead
will.
You
will see.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill birds to Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 29th,
2010.
How the hell are you?
Did you have a nice thanksgiving?
Did you,
did you hang out with all your family and all your friends?
Will you sitting at the table with someone that,
you know,
this time next year you're not going to be together.
You know,
and you're just trying to just sit there and plow through the fucking meal.
Go and God dammit.
Why didn't I break up with this bitch before I came home?
My fucking parents?
Why are you asking your questions?
She's not going to be here next year people,
this is all a rose.
Okay.
She was fun to bag.
We were having a good time and a,
I don't know what happened.
It got out of control and next thing you know she wanted to come to this thing
and I didn't have the balls to say no.
All right,
I fucked up.
I can tell you what.
I'm not going to get sucked into buying her a fucking Christmas gift.
Okay,
so you do the math.
You know when the fuck Christmases.
We all know when it is.
It's on the fucking 25th so 29th of November and she's out this bitches out
before Christmas cause I'm not feeling it past the fucking porch.
Thank you
Jesus Christ.
Nia,
I'm trying to do the podcast.
Can you not distract me?
Good Lord.
You know something you have to have a girlfriend or just does not appreciate
your creative space.
It's like you're sitting in here,
you're trying to give people something that they can enjoy for the week.
And what do you Donia you just come walking in here like this,
this amazing thing that's happening isn't happening.
Okay.
Nothing.
I don't get anything from you.
You're just gonna.
You're just going to collect your little belongings and then walk out of my life
for a couple hours.
Where are you going?
In and out.
Burger Nino.
All right.
She's gone.
No words of wisdom from her this week.
She's,
she's annoyed.
She's annoyed with me.
I've been traveling a lot lately.
Everybody,
it's because,
uh,
the tax man woe,
the tax,
the tax man's coming my way.
All right.
And as usual,
he's got his fucking handout with a scowl on his face.
So,
uh,
this is what always happens to me at the end of the year,
right before I take my month off,
you know,
to stare at my balls.
Okay?
Ah,
that's what I do.
During my Christmas break,
I could take a month off.
I just stare at my balls,
you know,
find my censure.
Um,
Jesus,
I'm gonna fucking goofy.
Goddamn move.
You know,
somebody hit my fucking car.
Can you believe that shit?
Why?
Yes,
Bill.
We can believe it.
Thousands of accidents happen every day.
All right.
So basically I was sitting at a red light,
uh,
me and my,
lovely compadre we were sitting there shooting the Shit,
you know,
and all of a sudden we just got hit from behind.
And uh,
I see this woman,
she's doing the gestures like,
and I,
I,
I that.
Yeah,
I am like south side.
She's making those faces,
right?
At least that's how I'm reading it.
Okay.
So then I got to pull over and then she starts pointing to different places
where I should be pulling over,
which is really fucking annoying me.
It's like,
listen,
bitch,
you hit my car.
How about I get to make a decision here?
You know,
like,
maybe we'll pull over here.
So we pull into this fucking Jiffy Lube.
She gets out,
turns out she's a fucking sweetheart.
She's a sweetheart,
right?
She's not a bad person.
She's like,
you know,
my dog was jumping around and went to go pick her up and I fucking rammed into
you.
So,
uh,
I look at my back bumper and it's got a nice little crease in it,
you know what I mean?
Like right down the side of Keith Richards face.
That's what I got like on a,
not on the,
the uh,
the side that you would see if you were standing behind it,
if you will,
creeping up right behind my car.
Like you were going to fuck it for some reason and you look down at it.
That part of the bumper,
the top part of the bumper,
that's what I'm trying to say.
I looked as crease a little bit.
Whatever,
you know the fuck.
I'm going to get a new bumper,
you know,
and then what some other person's going to hit me.
It's La,
it's a bumper.
Cars out here.
It's impossible.
I've done that a couple times.
I've gone out and I got my bumper replaced and literally a fucking week later
some asshole bumps into me.
So I'm just like,
fuck it.
Uh,
but what have we exchanged information?
And I,
and I go to leave.
And today,
Lo and behold,
I go for the first time,
I guess in a week to open and close the hatchback and it's not closing,
right.
So evidently she hit it hard enough that it did a little more damaged.
So I took it over to the place to get an estimate.
And of course the guy's like,
yeah,
you go fuck him with place the age you go fucking place data.
You know,
the gas tank,
you know,
it looks intact,
but it's probably a,
you know,
suffered sort of trauma.
So emotional trauma.
So he tells me it's going to be,
uh,
around two grand if not three grant
for this bullshit.
So I just had to call her back and just say,
listen,
I don't know if you got that kind of cash.
I ain't got that kind of fucking cash,
so why don't you report it to your fucking insurance company?
Because,
uh,
basically pull,
thought it was going to be a new bumper,
which is like,
you know,
five,
600 bucks depending on whether or not the fucking mechanic wants to have a keg
party that weekend.
You know,
and I don't know how to fix the shit.
So all you guys are going to send me emails,
do it.
There's no fucking way I know this.
No fucking way.
All right.
But I don't have time to find the fucking guy that's going to give me that.
I think actually,
whatever.
I have no fucking idea.
I have no idea what it's supposed to cost.
I drive a hybrid.
It's half a fucking spaceship.
God knows what the health behind those plastic bumpers.
But um,
so that's my day.
I just got off the beaten track.
What the fuck is today?
Today's the 29th of November.
This is the Monday morning podcast and I hope all you guys had a happy
thanksgiving.
I apologize last week for the volume.
I don't know what happened.
I don't know if I hit it or what,
but uh,
I'm surprised I didn't get more than the 30 complaints I got for how quiet it
is.
So this week it's going to be nice and loud.
Okay.
So called white man.
Um,
so anyways,
let's get through the podcast here.
I would,
I do this weekend I have after thanksgiving.
Um,
you know that this podcast has,
this podcast has a lot of momentum,
but not a lot of funny.
I'm just fucking,
you know,
you ever switched your drunk when you go down a flight of stairs and you start
the fall and you just like,
well fuck it.
I'm going in this direction anyways,
so you don't even try to break your fall.
That's basically how I've been doing this podcast.
So I'm going to take a breath,
let it out,
and I'm just going to fucking relax here.
I'm going to tell you about my weekend.
I had a phenomenal weekend.
Everybody just sit back,
take your fucking scrunchy out,
let your hair fall down around your shoulders.
Um,
no,
I went to a,
a,
I did the more theater,
the more,
the more theater up in,
uh,
Seattle,
Washington.
And um,
I'm going to tell you a fucking underrated right now,
Seattle,
Washington.
That place is,
uh,
that places the shit.
And if you ever decided,
you know,
you didn't want to fucking go overseas or go to some stupid fucking place just
because it had palm trees.
Uh,
Seattle is a,
is a,
it's just a fucking awesome city.
Although I got to tell you,
the weather is just as brutal as they say.
You know,
I have this new fancy phone.
I went out and got the droid incredible and
it always has the forecast.
If it's sunny out,
there's a sun.
If it's cloudy,
they just have a look.
They have a cloud.
The whole fucking weekend I was,
there was just this gray cloud on phone.
And I got to admit,
after three days it was really starting to fuck with me.
Um,
and even when they actually,
when you would look at the forecast and they would try to predict the next
couple of days,
they didn't have the balls to just say it was sunny.
They always throw a couple of clouds in front of the sun just to hedge their
bets.
Uh,
but anyways,
I did the,
uh,
the Moore theater up there with Paul Versey.
Uh,
my gambling associates slash comedian buddy.
Um,
and man,
I had a fucking great time.
If you have,
you listen every week,
you already know this shit.
If you're just tuning in for the first time where you haven't listened to a
couple of weeks,
the more theater is a legendary music venue up there in Seattle.
All those grunge bands played it.
Alison Change Soundgarden Nirvana,
pearl jam shot that video there for ra even flow.
Remember that when Eddie Vedder walked out and kind of fell off the balcony or
whatever the hell he did a,
as they would go,
Bam,
pick a tech,
a tech Gand band,
I could take it to gain whatever the fuck they were playing.
I never got into them until later on.
I never liked that first album,
even PLO.
I never got into that shit.
But anyways,
so I went there and um,
I found out the theaters like over a hundred years old and it had three tiers to
it and the upper most tier back in the day during a segregation when they had
the white section and the black section all the way up top,
there was the black section and they hadn't really done any different,
uh,
anything different to the theater I guess.
So they still had this CEP,
there's still a separate staircase to go all the way the fuck up there.
And I got to tell you,
cause I'm a history buff and that type of shit,
I'm like,
I got to see this,
I got to check this shit out.
So the guy takes us up there,
man.
It was fucking ridiculous.
You had to walk up like two flights of like,
you know,
10,
12 stairs and then it was just,
it's like you're going up the beginning part of the statue of Liberty before it
becomes that spiral staircase and it was like a fucking nine floor walk up.
And you got like fucking six levels up and literally your thighs are burning,
you know,
and we started joking,
this right here is why you don't see any white running backs at the pro level
anymore.
We used to just waltz right in to the fucking theater with our fucking doughy
white legs and we'd sit down right at the lower level.
Meanwhile,
the black dudes had to fucking walk up like 200 fucking stairs and they had the
lean forward,
you know,
to try to watch the show that strengthens the back muscles.
It's a fucking workout just to watch some jackass go up there and go,
Mami,
oh,
I love you.
How I love you Mami.
You know,
that's my fucking theory.
Either that or we just suck.
You know,
it's funny,
we actually went to a trailblazer's gave Friday night me and version and we had,
what do we bet?
We bet the fuck in a New Orleans who bet New Orleans was Sean.
Paul was sitting there watching it,
right?
And uh,
the fucking,
the game keep,
every time we go we're going to be winning a bet.
Portland comes back,
right?
And then all of a sudden a New Orleans,
I'm,
I'm sorry,
I'm fucking this story up because I keep thinking it's the Charlotte Hornets,
the New Orleans Hornets,
New Orleans comes flying down the court on this fast break and they'd dump it
off to this white dude.
And of course he misses the fucking layup.
And I swear to God,
me and [inaudible] both looked at each other and in unison went fucking white
guy,
you know,
and then we just started laughing.
But it's true.
It's like get them off the court,
you know,
give him a ref shirt.
Other than that,
get them the fuck out of there.
I got money on this fucking game.
It's annoying,
man.
It's fucking embarrassing.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what happened to us.
Um,
but I think some of them,
some of it has to do with that flight of stairs that I saw up there at the Moore
theater.
That's offensive.
Oh,
go fuck yourself.
Have a merry Christmas.
Anyways,
I,
um,
I got to tell you that show that I did at the,
uh,
the Moore theater there in Seattle was probably the best crowd that was like the
best crowd I've had since my standup special.
And I've had some great ones,
but I'm telling you,
man,
it was real.
I just want,
it was one of those shows where I just walked out and the first word,
I felt like it.
Uh,
it clicked.
Nia,
you look gorgeous.
You look gorgeous.
All right,
go get them.
Knock 'em dead.
Break a leg kicked our ass.
Look them right in the eye.
Tell him to go fuck themselves,
but with your eyes,
you know,
read those sites.
You get my right and you get my left.
I'm going to keep talking to you too.
You leave.
I'm in the middle of telling a story here.
Let me pick out the right earrings.
They're earrings that go with this outfit.
There's the jewelry box.
Where's the bracelet?
Oh my God.
Does anything take longer than your fucking girl to pick out a shit and get out
of the Goddamn Room?
That's all.
I'm trying to get you to yell at me near to add to the comedy.
Yeah,
I know,
but you know how I am.
You know I'm going to add you to it.
Am I supposed to act like you're not in the room?
That's fucking weird.
Like you're a guest.
Like I'm actually doing this in a radio show.
Yeah,
she's gone.
All right.
Anyways,
um,
the fuck was I talking about?
Yeah,
it was one of these shows,
like I went out there and I was ridiculously excited.
You know,
cause I'm a music geek.
You combine the fact that I'm a music Geek and then I'm a history buff.
He combined the whole thing.
It's a 100 year old theater downstairs.
It's all fucking cramped.
They,
these little doorways,
you know,
cause back in the day we weren't all hopped up on these fucking,
whatever the fucking horse tranquilizers they put into the chicken nowadays.
So now we're all like at least five 11 for some fucking reason.
You know,
they had those little douche bags with the powdered wigs a hundred years ago.
Right.
Who Actually,
these people stop wearing powdered wigs.
Gow Fuck Yourself.
I know.
I'm just saying you ever seen those old pictures,
those little runt sitting there and making the fucking,
uh,
the railroads are standing there with their evil fucking white guy.
Racist Mustache is the,
uh,
the Chinese guys built it,
right.
At least they built it from San Francisco.
All right.
People,
I'm a history buff.
I didn't say I know the history.
I just thought I just sorta walk by it.
Every once in a while.
I read a couple of plaques in the museum.
I'm that guy.
Then I deliberately try to shoe horn the information.
I just read it at a,
at a,
at a museum and to whatever conversation is going on at a party,
you know,
I was kidding him.
A fucking moron.
Anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
So,
um,
I was really excited to do the show and I walked out there and it was just,
just from,
I don't know,
some shows you just go out there and from the first word you just lock in with
the crowd.
And uh,
that's what happened.
And they were,
yeah,
they were just,
they were just a great crowd.
Totally went along for the ride.
For some reason they didn't turn the fucking heat on in the building.
Um,
and I think that's what happened.
I just started making fun of how fucking cold it was and then that just sort of
opened my brain up and I went off and I had a great time and I want to thank
everybody up in Seattle who came out to,
uh,
came out to the shelf.
So that was my weekend.
I'll wait a minute,
then I went to the Seahawks game on Sunday and uh,
the fuck did I go to and I'm fucking white.
Dot.
I came around.
What the Hell I did,
went to the Seahawks game with Versie.
That's right.
We will walk into the stadium going,
should we bet the fucking Seahawks?
Oh,
we see.
Should we bet the chiefs in both those teams have fucked me over the whole God
damn year and a,
we bet the fucking Seahawks.
You know,
I was just sick of going to games and rooting against the home team.
So I actually bet with my heart,
like a fucking asshole.
And the second I showed up and I saw Pete Carroll and his entire coaching staff
in those fucking Khaki Docker's,
I don't know why they're wearing those things.
You know like they're going to go play the fucking Ryder Cup.
This is football and it was a,
the game started off awesome.
First of all,
it's the loudest fucking Stadium Professional Football Stadium I've ever been to
and I think it's louder than even when I went to western Michigan,
the big house as far as I can remember,
I'd have to go to a Michigan game again.
It was louder than Ohio state,
I think it was the loudest fucking football game I'd ever been to was it was,
I know you guys think I'm exaggerating,
but I'm not bullshitting.
First of all,
they started off and every fucking week they have some guy come out there and
they've got this big thing out there.
The 12th man,
which is the crowd,
a phone for non sports fans is 11 guys.
In any given time when you play in the game live in guys on defense,
11 guys on offense,
that type of shit.
So the 12th guy's the fucking fan,
little bit of pandering,
but you know these fans earn it.
So just start the game.
They have some fucking,
they just find some dude that's gonna fucking ramp the crowd up to come out and
raise the 12 12th man flag.
Like we're going to Goddamn or like you already conquered some shit.
All right?
Never.
Denley earlier this year on some sort of veteran's day,
they brought out some old guy who stormed the beaches of Normandy,
came out to get his purple hearts and all that and the poor bastard.
It took him like 20 minutes to raise the flag because he was so old.
But it just,
the fact that the fucking guy storm normally the place and a place almost
collapsed people flipping out.
So the week we went,
they brought the guy,
I can't remember his name,
that actor,
uh,
who was in top gun viper,
I believe his name was to do two flew with Maverick's dad deck guy came out
there.
So they're playing the top gun music and all that.
And it should have been cheesy,
but it was,
it was Kinda cheesy.
It was fucking hilarious and a,
that's a guilty pleasure.
Everybody loves that movie.
So the place is just going fucking nuts.
And I'm feeling like,
uh,
I'm feeling like we're going to win.
I bet.
And then Kansas City gets the ball and immediately first play from scrimmage,
castle rolls out and just fucking throws one 12 yards first down.
Right.
And all of a sudden I hear this voice behind me and I,
it,
I just say,
this guy just go and they'll fucking sea hawks,
quarterback sock.
Right.
And I turned around and it's this big fat Kansas City chiefs fan,
and he was so fat.
You could just tell he knew about football and this son of a bitch was right
because they got burned the entire fucking gay.
I don't want to talk about the rest of it.
So he ended up losing the money we won on the fucking Portland game.
We ended up giving it back.
But,
uh,
I don't know.
It was still an awesome time.
We ended up meeting some people from the show and they had these seats right
down on the end zone.
So we fucking went all the way down for the second half.
And you're actually basically sitting on the field and uh,
you know what sucked was Seattle actually scored a touchdown.
They threw a bomb is 50 yard bomb for a touchdown.
And I was in the suite taking a piss.
And when I come walking out,
as I'm walking out trying to see past all these people stuffing their faces with
Nachos,
I just see these male cheerleaders running around with those Seahawk flags,
you know,
out on the field and the crowd's going nuts.
And I was like,
you gotta be shitting me.
So other than that,
it was a great fucking time.
So we had an awesome time up there in Seattle and went down to the,
uh,
the fish market,
their guts.
It was just,
it was awesome.
It was,
it was just,
it was fucking phenomenal.
50 if it just could have been a little sunny,
it would have been the best weekend I had all goddamn year.
Other than other than the,
the depressing gray skies and you,
it's funny,
he's everything.
I was joking on stage.
Everything in Seattle is made,
I swear to God from the same bag of concrete,
see exact same consistency.
It's the exact same fucking color.
And on those overcast days,
it just,
the horizon just blends in with that concrete and it says,
I can really see why people fucking blow their brains out up there.
You know,
if you're not careful,
if you're not fucking careful,
you can end up like that fellow there,
that fellow from that,
from that,
that place who,
who did that stuff?
Remember that guy?
Um,
you know what I noticed about Paul Brizy last week?
I was giving him shit and I can't give him shit this week cause I went one in
three.
I officially do not know shit about football when it comes to fucking gambling.
And evidently,
uh,
I don't know shit about a football without gambling because I said the Steelers,
we're going to be the team to beat fucking assholes.
You can't cover against the God damn bills.
What the fuck is wrong with that team?
They got the defense.
They got Ben Roethlisberger is back.
Is it because he can't rape anybody anymore?
It's fucking thrown off his game.
I don't know what's going on,
but they got all,
maybe they got some injuries.
That's another thing.
Why I suck at gambling is cause I don't,
I can't watch ESPN because they just hype shit through the fucking roof.
Like that Monday night football game,
Michael Vick,
remember that?
Thought there was over,
just give him the Superbowl.
True.
Michael Vick,
Michael Vick.
What was gene tonight?
We,
Michael Vick.
It was fucking over.
They weren't even addressing the fact that he was doing it against the hapless
Washington.
Fucking Redskins
didn't even mention that.
And then what happens the next week they played the giants.
Giants beat him,
I believe contained Vic this week.
I still got their fucking voices in my head.
Michael Vick,
fucking Michael Vick,
right?
So what do I do?
I fucking put money on the Goddamn Eagles in the fucking bears.
Kicked the shit out of him.
So once again,
and I even said on this pot podcast when somebody tried to say that Michael Vick
was the best quarterback in the fucking league because he kicked the shit out of
the Redskins one fucking week.
And it's the exactly the reason why I keep trying to tell people that Peyton
manning isn't as great as people are saying,
I give up,
but you know something.
I've actually,
I give up with that argument.
I officially fucking give up because this guy after my show in Seattle,
just started the argument with me and then followed up and sent me an email.
And one of the points he wanted to make as to the reason why Tom Brady was an
inferior quarterback was because of his knee injury.
He said something that if Tom Brady knew how to scramble and didn't suck so bad,
he wouldn't have injured his fucking knee.
Now that's a funny fucking line,
but this guy was actually serious.
So at this point,
it's just like whatever,
people like who they like.
So go ahead.
Like who you like,
I don't give a fuck.
Anyways.
Um,
I finally got bored with that whole fucking thing.
And also I got to,
I just,
I just don't believe in the Patriots.
I just can't get behind that fucking defense.
Bella checks a fucking genius can make the,
make the adjustments,
but we're not going to go anywhere with that giving up 24 to 30 points every
fucking week.
Did you see Fatboy slim there?
Uh,
uh,
what's his face?
Rex Ryan trying the,
the age old world against us fucking speech,
you know,
trying to paint his team as the underdog.
Do you think his team's dumb enough to fucking believe it?
I do.
You know,
allow people out there that check of the needs and Beth came and the leg.
Well,
we have that and one of those guy and he gives his stupid fat John Wayne Smile.
Ah,
Jesus fucking Christ cookie dough wheat and fucking patent looking jackass.
I'm so fucking sick of them.
It's how to fuck you guys kicked the shit out of us when the fuck you getting
off of this fucking underdog talk you fucking Pansy.
What are you already hedging your bet?
You afraid you're going to fucking lose you faggot.
Oh,
there's no game in the world that I want to win more than this Monday night
coming up next week.
The patriots versus the jets.
I want,
I,
I can't remember the last time.
This is worse than Celtics Lakers and you know what the sad thing is is we're
not going to fucking win cause at defense sucks fucking assholes.
24 to 30 points a game.
There's no fucking way you can give that up.
The jets have to good at defense those mother fuckers and now the Steelers
aren't stepping on maybe the ravens.
Maybe the ravens will say,
but that's all I need.
That's all I need.
I don't give a fuck longest somebody beats the jets in the playoffs.
I am going to be excited if that fucking half ass bullshit fucking team wins the
super bowl,
that fucking team that wins by the skin of that goddamn teeth hasn't fucking
dominated anybody but my shit ass fucking defensive team,
it gets going to kill me.
It's absolutely going to fucking kill me.
I'm going to,
I don't know what I'm going to do.
I'm going to have,
I would say I cancel the podcast for two weeks,
but that would be the bitch move after I talked to all his shit.
So I'm going to have to come in and take my shit if it happens.
But luckily I don't think it's going to happen,
but I got to admit,
I got no fucking faith.
I got no faith.
The fuck you let the lion scored 24 points on you
got trampled by the browns were fucking horrific on defense.
We're good for the first two doubts.
What grade of what great with dead.
Then third down,
I think that our defense is just having so much fun being out there that they're
like,
yeah,
let's just lit up 12 yards on a run.
Let's do it on a run.
They'll eat up some of the clock.
That'd be fucking awesome.
Um,
who else?
Fuck me.
Last week I,
Lila,
calm,
blaming everybody,
but myself for my,
uh,
for my,
my awful Pyxis this week.
Actually bet on Peyton manning.
You know,
all you douchebags telling me such a great fucking quarterback with his three
picks.
You know what,
why,
why wouldn't I realize at this point after the chargers have essentially what
are they beating the cults at home?
Like what nine times in a fucking row a couple of times in the playoffs.
Look at Peyton manning now.
Now that he has no fucking tools.
Now look at him.
Look how average he looks and just fucking pissing people off our name.
Let's get off this fucking subject.
So that's my prediction.
Next.
I actually,
I think next week I think it's gonna be a tight fucking game,
but I just can't see us.
Uh,
it wouldn't surprise me because I can't believe he'd beat the Steelers,
but I,
I just,
I can't get behind a fucking team that lets up all those goddamn points.
They're fucking old lady.
We did.
Our defense should be dressed like matadors
with big red capes.
Just letting receivers and running backs go down the field Olay.
Um,
all right.
I think that's about enough.
See that wasn't that bad.
I'm trying to tone down the fucking NFL Shit I get.
I'm getting really,
I'm never doing this again because I realized there's no fucking way I can talk
for 17 weeks about anything.
I am absolutely bored shitless with the sports talk with that specific shit.
I can't fucking do it anymore.
But now I have to hang in there cause I've talked so much God damn shit.
So maybe that'll be the engine.
Maybe that'll be the entertaining part of this podcast.
Listening to me talk about something I don't give him slowly not giving a fuck
about anymore.
Um,
all right.
Oh,
I know what I want to talk.
I wanted to make fun of Paul Versey.
Do you guys remember that?
Fucking,
uh,
you remember good fellas?
Maybe that little movie,
Goodfellas,
it was just a little art house movie that kind of came and went and theaters
really quickly.
What was the name of that character in the beginning?
One of the,
uh,
Jimmy two times or whatever.
Get the papers,
get the papers.
Remember that Paul Versey is fucking,
uh,
Paulie three times.
It's not that he says shit twice or three times.
It's like,
I don't,
I don't know if he thinks that you can't hear him or f if he starts to make a
point and he realizes that the wall that he wanted to jump over with his point
is like six feet higher than he thought.
So he's got to run back another 10 paces.
I'd never met a guy who starts and then stops and then restarts his fucking
sentences more times than this guy who fucking at the game the other day.
Right.
I can't remember what we were just talking about something and this,
this is him
trying to make this point.
He goes,
goes,
you know people talk shit.
And he goes,
no.
He goes,
you know,
he goes,
people talk,
people talk shit,
dude.
People Talk Shit when they think they know what's going on
the whole fucking weekend.
It was driving me nuts.
Like watch it.
It was like the verbal equivalent.
You know,
when you watch those reality shows,
you know,
and they're about ready to weigh some fat fuck.
And then they do the scale and you're like,
oh fuck,
what's going to happen?
And then they go to commercial and then when they come back from compared
commercial,
they go right back to the fat fuck getting on the scale.
It's just like,
just wait the fucker.
Just weigh him.
That's what verse he does.
Robinson Cano,
Dude Robinson Cano was four,
four,
four last night.
He does,
he,
he fucking,
he bangs against the door once just to see if,
oh,
if it's solid or it's particle board and then he,
he figures out how far back he has to run.
Don't you heard it here first?
All right.
The New York giants,
dude,
the New York giants are going to fucking run the table hurting here first.
Paul,
I heard it the first nine times you said it.
I swear to God,
it's,
it's like he's got some sort of like a,
it's not a,
a speech impediment.
It's like a brain impediment.
He states starts to make a point and uh,
then there's like a heckler in his head.
Just go,
no Paul Unit.
You're not saying it with enough confidence.
Like there's a director going cut.
Cut.
All right,
Paul.
No,
no,
no.
We,
we love what you're doing here.
We love what you're doing here.
But if you could just come with a little more emotion this time,
a little more fucking emotion.
Um,
all right,
that'll,
that'll be about enough of that shit.
I'm really,
this is,
this is what travel does to me this time of fucking year.
I fly through a fucking point and then I slammed into a brick wall and then I'm
done with it.
All right.
I'm done with fucking sports,
you know,
and that some of you on this podcast,
I'm fucking done with you.
You know,
you are,
uh,
let's get the youtube videos for the week.
Ladles and Sylvan.
Um,
and they,
they've actually at this point,
uh,
kind of broken off into two because we have the clips from the bad movies,
the great bad movies.
And I'm telling you some of the shit you guys are sending me is unbelievable.
And all these videos will be up on the [inaudible] podcast.com.
She's,
she'll check this one out.
You got to see this one.
This is actually something that I brought up.
This is not a bad movie.
This is actually an incredible movie.
It's the original Manchurian candidate.
But I had mentioned a long time ago that there's a fight scene in there,
Frank Sinatra versus Asian dude.
And,
um,
according to Frank Sinatra,
it's the first karate film,
the first Kung Fu film ever done in American cinema.
And you have to see how fucked it mean.
Especially now.
I mean,
I don't know how to fucking fight,
but I've watched enough UFC and you look at the stance,
the stance is that some of the stances they get in about three quarters into the
fight are just as ridiculous as that karate kid.
Um,
fear the sparrow or whatever the fuck that,
the name of that stance,
that bird cloth thing that he would do.
Um,
anyways,
I got to it's Manchurian candidate in 1962 fight.
You can look it up if you want to,
but we have all these videos listed nice and neatly along with some pictures
from my trip to Seattle,
if you'd like to see where we sat at the game.
Me and Mr [inaudible] took a picture of the nice fluffy fish and chips.
I got fucking unbelievable seafood.
That's a great place to take your,
your,
your girlfriend or your wife.
I fucked up.
I should have brought my girl,
you know,
but you know,
I was going to a couple of sporting events and she doesn't like sports,
you know,
when you date a girl doesn't like sports.
You take to a sporting event and all they talk about has how pretty the grass
looks.
And then by like the second inning,
they're just bored shitless.
Uh,
that's my experience when I take Nia places.
So,
uh,
you know,
I don't,
I don't fucking know who's kidding,
who I fucked up.
Anyways,
let's plow head.
Um,
the second,
um,
great bad movie.
Here we go.
Uh,
I drink your blood 1970 trailer.
This is the fact that they made this fucking movies.
It's just,
it's unbelievable.
But when you think back to it how there was no internet and uh,
just how early on they were into like those slasher kind of movies when you
actually watched this trailer,
like this is the kind of,
it's like very like you're really going after the serial killer sort of
demographic.
I bet like Ted Bundy and those fucking maniacs went to go see this stuff back
when it was shocking.
Now it's hilarious,
but it's really,
uh,
it's just really bizarre,
really fucking bizarre.
Um,
all right.
And his er,
regular youtube videos for the week.
Um,
this one was actually already shown on tosh point.
Oh,
but this one is so funny.
I don't like to,
to show videos that have already been shown on that show,
but just in case you missed the episode,
this is fucking hilarious.
Remember that when I talked about last week,
man versus booze.
If you did that,
this dude tries to chug a bottle of patroned,
which by the way,
guys is really fucking dangerous.
All right?
If you actually did it successfully,
you would die.
Which is why this guy projectile vomits.
That's your body basically saying let's get this shit the fuck outta here so we
don't die.
Um,
the name of the video,
you want to search a Joe Breezy patroned challenge and uh,
this guy is fucking hilarious.
The shit talk and he does in front of it is,
is almost as funny as when he pukes is,
you know,
this guy's a fucking riot.
He's like mocking the shit talk.
I think that you see on a lot of these uh,
videos of that you see on reality TV.
It's hilarious.
Um,
another one you guys see a lot of Christmas lights on.
You're on the houses as you driving around a check out.
This one heavy metal Christmas light show.
That one was actually on live,
leak.com heavy metal Christmas light show.
And then there's another video here.
This one is awesome as far as like,
it's really interesting if anybody's into animals and you can explain this one.
It's crows verse Cat First Cat Street fight.
And this person put this unbill almost like they custom made this music for this
fight.
It's fucking incredible.
He's two cats.
I'm not,
I'm not going to ruin it for you.
Just,
you just got to see it.
It's fucking incredible.
Um,
another video,
I love this one.
It's called a censored 8,000,
800 pennies.
Um,
and it basically,
this dude looks like a college aged kid.
He got his car towed and he had to walk 15,
20 miles to get home.
The next day called up,
he found out where his car was and they wanted $88 to get it out.
So he said,
fuck it.
I got $88,
and he showed up with 8,000,
800 pennies.
Uh,
most of them unrolled and he brought it in and he's like,
it's legal tender.
You have to take it.
And ladies like,
I'm not going to take this,
I'm not taking this.
And he's like,
you got to take it's legal tender.
She's like,
I'm not taking it.
He goes,
fine.
I'm calling the cops,
which he did,
and you got to see it.
It's fucking awesome.
I don't want to ruin it,
but it's awesome.
Uh,
is another good one.
A speeding ticket fail.
Just a quick one for you.
People who don't like to watch a 10 minute videos and uh,
this is another great one.
Do this.
A really funny fucking filmmakers and actors and shit just fucking around.
Just regular people are on Youtube,
man.
These dudes are really funny,
especially the guy who fucking punches the pig.
And this one,
uh,
this is called Turbo Bacon epic Thanksgiving,
epic mealtime.
Uh,
you know,
I think I'd like to you every year they come up with a new fattening way to cook
a Turkey.
These guys just take it to the fucking nth degree.
They make like a 7,900 calorie,
uh,
Turkey man.
It's fucking insane.
And uh,
just watch the part where he's tenderizing the pig.
That's my favorite fucking part,
really made me laugh out loud.
Um,
and let's get to the overrated,
underrated for this week.
Did I not get an advice one?
Why did I,
God dammit,
that's usually a nice fucking time filler.
Somebody asks me some fucking advice.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
speaking of advice,
uh,
did not Boosie,
still have not boost.
I am 44 days in 44 is a very famous number in professional sports.
Right.
You all know who I'm talking about.
Who's the most famous number?
and all of professional sports.
Think about it.
That's right.
You got it.
Robert Newhouse,
the old fullback used to block for Tony Doerr set.
You're absolutely right though.
And it's fucking Reggie Jackson was,
was was Hank Aaron 44.
I don't fucking know.
You know what people really drop the ball on was the obscure sports facts.
I thought that people were going to work really gonna keep that one going.
I thought I had a new segment and it,
it just died a quick death.
You know,
like one of those critically acclaimed shows.
Critics love it.
Eight other people are watching it and then it just fucking gets canceled
because no one else gives a shit.
And then what happens?
All right,
comes out on DVD and then everybody loves it.
Why they ever cancel this?
Alright.
Overrated.
Underrated for the week.
No,
I'm not done talking about booze.
I'm 44 fucking days in.
All right.
Uh,
all I got as I got San Francisco this week,
just as far as tentation goes.
I got San Francisco this week.
I'm playing COBB's comedy club for the first time.
I've always been a punchline guy.
Now I'm going across town playing cobb's comedy club this Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday and Sunday.
Um,
and I'm also doing a book signing in.
I got to get the,
I got to get you guys not a book signing.
I don't have a book.
I'm doing a DVD signing.
It's for,
uh,
to support,
research for AIDS and Amanda.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
What the fuck are,
you know the silly,
how dumb I am.
I didn't know the name of the bookstore.
I keep thinking Brookstone begins with a B.
What's that bookstore everybody goes to see the only one left,
isn't it?
Wow.
I just went fucking blank.
Um,
yeah,
I'm going to be at one of those borders,
borders,
bookstore.
I want to be up there,
uh,
doing a book,
a book signing,
a DVD signing on Wednesday night before I do my gig.
And I absolutely love San Francisco and a,
if you guys know any cool places to eat cause I'm not drinking.
I'm really enjoying this.
I went to a,
I think it was called the steel diner in um,
in Seattle.
Me and versing,
we got like the best fucking fish,
most the freshest seafood.
You've,
you've ever fucking had those,
those goddamned deadliest catch guys show up.
You can buy shit right off the goddamn boats if you want to.
It's unbelievable.
Uh,
best fish and chips I've had,
uh,
I'm eating them like Jesus,
this is like light as air then,
you know,
cause it's deep fried and shit.
Afterwards I felt like I had a boot in my stomach,
but it was absolutely delicious.
So anyways,
I'm not boozing if you guys know of any,
uh,
any,
any cool restaurants,
if that man versus food guy went there and I don't want to eat the fucking
challenge thing,
but if he went there like that Burger,
I was trying to remember the name of Juicy Lucy,
the one in Minneapolis.
I missed out on that.
So if this,
if there's something,
whatever people in San Francisco,
late night,
you're drunk or you're going just,
or you just went there as a kid,
you had to get this sandwich or this pizza,
whatever,
please let me know where it is because uh,
I need some,
uh,
productive shit to be doing rather than sitting around thinking about booze and
cause I got to admit that weather up there in Seattle,
you know,
it makes you want to eat comfort food and then just go out and drink whatever
local beer that they have.
Ah,
fuck.
That's what I really miss about booze and you know,
I'll tell you a great time to go to Cleveland,
Ohio,
Cleveland,
this time a year.
Great.
When you get into December,
go out there and go to a browns game.
They got a great team and they got this fucking Christmas Ale out there.
That is the shit and it's an extra couple of,
uh,
I think they have one in,
in,
in Pittsburgh too.
This is a really knocked me back on the wagon.
Why don't you guys sit,
send me a list if you guys in those colder cities,
just because that seems to be where they only put those,
those beers out,
those seasonal beers that come out.
Man,
a fucking unbelievable.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
Am I gonna be able to make it to the Rose Bowl?
I'm actually contemplating not drinking at the Rose Bowl and this year rather
than going with,
with one other drunk buddy,
I'm going with two other three other,
I got a crew of four and uh,
I dunno,
for some reason I want to see if I can go 100 days.
I know I can,
but uh,
I got to admit,
man,
I was in Seattle was fucking really difficult,
really difficult.
But every day,
every day you wake up when you didn't drink the night before you wake up,
you feel good.
You know,
you work out,
go down,
you get yourself a juice,
you sit there stone sober.
Don't have any good stories to tell because you didn't fucking do anything the
night before.
And you sit there bored shitless with the,
but you have the exact same brain cells you had the night before.
People,
I think the level of brain cells you have left is,
it is exactly equal to the amount of fun that you had in life as a theory.
I just came up with,
you know,
if you have half your brain cells left,
you enjoyed half of your life.
A fucking makes no sense.
But you know what I mean.
All right,
let's stop talking about boots.
Cause I swear to God,
I still have one of those Murphy's stout in the fucking roof.
I keep leaving in there.
I can't get myself to dump it down the sink because it's such a good beer,
you know?
And I keep thinking that some friend out here that I don't really have is going
to come swinging by.
Would you like a bear?
I'm going to pour it to him.
Hands.
Fucking trembling.
Like a Goddamn crack addict.
Um,
anyways,
overrated.
Underrated for the week here.
Um,
all right.
Overrated laptops.
Uh,
the batteries fucked after a month.
So when you move to scratch your ass,
you'd delete half of your work.
Isn't that the fucking truth?
I'm underrated.
Throwing snowballs on cars are at cars.
No easier way to get your ass kicked.
Wow.
Now there's something to do.
If you're not drinking and you still want an adrenaline,
adrenaline rush,
you know,
you remember that as a kid when he threw a snowball at a car and you got him
real good and the guy slammed on his brakes and fucking pulled over that fucking
adrenaline rush as you turned around and your snow suit and your big stupid
boots trying to run in like a foot of snow that actually comes up to mid thigh
because you're so small.
Oh Man.
That was fun.
That was a good fucking time back in the day.
That's another reason why people always think it snowed more when you were a
kid.
It's because you were a fucking midget walking around in the snow though.
When I was a kid,
we used to have snowstorms.
Hey,
would come up to your waist,
you know?
Yeah,
dude,
you are for
five fucking years old.
Remember that Shit,
you're knocked out your front teeth and your dad's shoes,
you will little you dumb.
Fuck.
Um,
alright.
Overrated coffee houses.
This guy says,
I can't stand these places.
People show up in their scarves and laptops,
ex,
uh,
that are exclusively apple.
May I add and park themselves in a booth for three hours?
You're going to get a coffee.
You have to stump stumbled through some college kids project than stand in the
longest line known demand.
All the while listening,
some mellow hippie with a beard playing his acoustic guitar.
Is it just me or these places stink?
Um,
I,
I think they do stink.
You know,
I just heard some laughter downstairs.
I wonder if they're actually listening to the podcast or they're laughing at how
unfunny this shit is.
Um,
and then I have one here,
underrated Seahawks fans.
I got a whole new fucking respect for those people to chair on that God awful
fucking performance.
They hung in there right to the fucking end and a lot of them were pissed at the
end of the game when with like a minute left,
they just took a knee.
You know for the last two or three fucking plays,
even though you're down by 20 points,
can you go down swinging?
I'll tell you that's that Pete Carroll ball standing up there and his fucking
Docker's.
Huh?
That fucking that.
You know what he's like?
He's like in the coach's witness protection program.
That's kind of like what he did.
It's like the shit hit the fan.
He's Henry Hill.
He's the Henry Hill and Mike Paul Versey.
He's dude.
He's the Henry Hale.
A fucking coaches.
Look at his contagious now.
He really is though.
He got all the glory at USC and then the second the shit he told Sanchez,
he left too early and made all this big fucking speech and then the second the
shit went down and people start talking about Reggie Bush and all this other
bullshit.
He just fucking skips town.
Has he even commented on it or did he pull that bullshit where they just look,
I'm here to coach the Seattle Seahawks.
If you have some Seattle Seahawks questions,
I'll be happy to answer those.
Anything else?
I'm not answering.
That is all in the past,
but blah,
blah,
blah.
Did he do that bull shit,
son of a bitch?
Oh big but hope he fucking flames out and it has nothing to do with Seahawks
fans.
I hope he flames out in Seattle and then he goes back with his tail between his
legs.
Right.
It goes back to the college coaching level.
He'll probably get a coaching job in the sec.
Right.
And we all know that the SEC has the best fucking teams.
It's got the bets coaching and it's got the best players and I don't think that
he can fucking stand up to the fucking sec conference.
He was out there in the PAC 10 bunch of God damn pansies out there other than
Jim Har bar over.
Fuck you say his name,
Captain Comeback there.
That fucking guy can coach.
There's a guy who should go to the pros.
Pete Carroll,
when you make a good play,
he goes,
Woo.
You ever seen that?
Like fucking ric flair.
But it's not funny.
I remember that.
I haven't,
does he still do that shit?
I remember that back when he said,
coach the Patriots,
they score a touchdown.
They cut to him on the sidelines.
You know,
all the fat fuck defensive coordinators are like,
like they just murdered somebody got that look,
a rage on their face at the play work.
And Pete would be in the middle with his hand straight up in the air and just go
on,
right.
Woo.
And I was just like,
this guy's a pussy.
And then he went to the,
you went to the fucking,
uh,
Trojans.
And I was like,
all right,
maybe I was wrong.
Maybe I was wrong about this guy.
It turns out I was right.
Go back down to the college level with your fucking dockers.
You fucking Richie Cunningham
coming out there,
you know,
dress like you're going to host an am radio show.
That's it.
That's how you fucking lead your team to battle.
I can understand if you're a fat fuck like Rex Ryan,
he had to wear those soccer moms stretchy pants.
I don't understand that shit.
A second.
Jared shape.
Pete Carroll.
What the fuck are,
you know something I even know what kind of pants coaches were,
but I know they're not dose.
What are you going to a fucking sock hop?
Oh my God.
You know,
to have money on that fucking guy.
If they should just show me the pants that they're coaching staff was going to
fucking where I would've put money on the chiefs who fucked me when they played
the bills.
How's kitten?
Who?
I don't know how to gamble.
Thank God Paul Versey doesn't either.
I'm actually still two games ahead of them.
I'm only saying that because I know he's listening to this shit at this point.
Um,
all right,
Paul Versey by the way.
Absolutely fucking destroyed growing by leaps and bounds.
You know,
he's jumped out of the little standup nest.
He's flapping his wings.
He didn't hit the ground.
I think this one's going to make it,
you know,
you know comedians are,
when we start off,
you ever see those things when like a,
the little turtles hatch,
you ever see them on the,
on the discovery channel and then you,
they start fucking going down the beach.
Those cute little turtles and those fucking birds come in and swoop up like 90%
of them and only 2% make it out to the water.
Right.
Okay.
That's where [inaudible] is right now.
He's not in the water.
He's not on the beach.
It's getting a little wet
and you want the birds are,
those are the broads in your life that don't support yet.
Yeah.
Just fucking scoopy up in your fucking dreams and they fly away with you and
hate your fucking soul.
Bill.
Do you have anything positive to say about women?
Um,
yes.
Yes I do.
I sat next to a pretty lady on the plane yesterday,
you know,
just a beautiful girl.
Cleavage half a titty.
Okay.
But a nice teddy,
you know what I mean?
Not Obnoxious,
nice healthy BEACOPP just sitting there just made you,
you know?
Yeah.
Just something nice to look at during the turbulence.
Like,
you know,
it's not all bad.
Okay.
Fact that this plane is probably going to crash and because it's a jet,
when the engine's cut out,
you can't even glide.
Is tendencies actually to just turn over and I'm actually be hanging from my
fucking seat belt,
you know?
Yeah.
There's some fucking free peanuts stuck to my face.
If we're pulling four g's,
going back to mother earth,
you know,
if I have the neck muscles,
maybe I can glance over at that cleavage right before we fucking enter the
fucking ground.
Jesus Christ bill.
Okay.
Um,
you know what I'm doing?
I'm,
I,
I'm not even listening to what the fuck I'm saying.
Oh,
you know,
it was great.
Was uh,
we actually got hooked up with tickets while we were supposed to be hooked up
with tickets to the Seattle game.
You know,
it's just one of those things.
You have to have a friend who just says,
Oh yeah,
dude,
I can fucking hook you up.
I guy got the tickets,
don't you worry about it.
Right.
And then you show up and they're not there and you just realize that the guys
all talk,
I'm just fucking,
I could just in case he's listening,
but just fucking around.
We had a good time,
buddy of ours hooked us up with tickets and uh,
they,
I guess they fucked up,
you know,
at the front office.
They're in Seattle.
You know what it was.
They were too busy laughing at Pete Carroll and they're fucking Goddamn Chino's
as they walked down the down the fucking hall that they actually got,
they got us two tickets for next week.
Hey,
you know what,
I dunno if I should do this,
but there's two tickets waiting under my name.
Uh,
but you need an,
you'd need an ID.
There's two tickets waiting under my name for next week.
Seattle game.
Walk up to the,
we'll call and just be like,
yes.
Hello.
I'm William [inaudible] and I would like my tickets.
Please do you have an id but you out of your fucking mind.
I've been on premium blend.
Give me my fucking tickets.
Um,
if there's a bill burr who lives in Seattle,
go down there.
There's two tickets waiting for you.
This whole podcast has gone off the fucking Ralph 52 minutes in.
Technically I could pull the rip cord.
Hang on here.
I'm trying to find an advice.
One to try.
Oh,
here we go.
Girlfriend problems.
Let's click on this.
Uh,
the,
I don't want to read that one.
I thought it was gonna be a nice long one.
Eat Up some time.
Bill.
My,
uh,
girlfriend's a coochie kind of smells like the inside of my gym sneaker and I
was wondering how I am I bring that up.
Uh,
fuck.
Come on.
Advice.
I know there was one is an overrated,
underrated.
I already did that.
Jesus.
All right people.
I'm going to be at COBB's comedy club next week.
I'm just going to end the fucking podcast.
Come on bill.
Why didn't you do your homework?
You know what is great.
This is my last road gig that I am doing
before my,
uh,
you fucking cunt.
You know what?
I can't,
I can't scroll and,
and talk at the same time.
Airbag prank old man.
Welcome to Seattle,
Seattle DVD order advice.
Let's look at the Seattle DVD order cause I thought I asked for three.
I have confirmed the tracking Deni damp.
The third,
the venue.
All right,
everything's good.
Okay.
You know what?
Fuck it.
That's the podcast for this week.
God bless all of you.
Thanks for listening.
I thought I had an advice one here.
Uh,
thank you for your contributions.
I hope you guys all had a really nice thanksgiving.
Ameri thanksgiving.
I hope you have a merry Christmas.
You get to start your shopping.
That's something I could talk about.
I haven't started my shopping yet.
I'm at that weird age where,
uh,
you know,
I don't have any fucking kids so I don't have to do that.
All my friends are too fucking old.
What am I going to buy them,
you know,
worth the Cologne and new shirt age.
Uh,
you know,
everyone in my family has their own fucking lives.
They have their own.
So my overheads really not that high.
All you gotta do is just buy something for my girl and I'm done and I'm done.
You know what?
You don't actually,
I'm thinking of getting her is uh,
I was driving by Arby's the other night and I saw on underneath the sign that
they have these Christmas gift packs and a,
it's this booklet.
It's really cool because they have like everything,
like coupons for everything on their menu at a discount because a,
you know what,
if she doesn't want one of those awful roast beef sandwiches,
maybe she just wanted to go,
go in there and get the fucking,
the uh,
the onion rings.
You know?
Wouldn't it be awesome to do that just as a fuck you to the,
to the pressure of,
of,
of getting something nice for the woman in your life.
It just,
one year you just went out and just bought her a gift like that.
How do you think your would read what you can't go that you can't call that low
cause that's like insulting.
You can't get her a fucking coupon.
But you know,
it gets to the point like how much fucking money do I got to spend on you?
You know,
what have you bought her like a really nice bathrobe,
you know,
that's something she can wear every day when she gets out of the shower.
Really Nice and comfy and you give it to her and she thinks like,
Ooh,
this is just one of the buildup gifts.
And it's like no,
that,
that is the gift.
That is the one,
there it is.
Yeah.
Barry Christmas,
you know that it will be a great thing just to,
you know,
that's what I know.
Something that's a great idea.
If you actually got us some really nice,
do something like that,
just act like this.
No other gifts.
And then just watch her stewing and figuring out how to play it,
you know,
because she's mad at you.
All right.
Cause you didn't get her something good enough,
but she has to play it right.
Because if she flips out too much,
she's going to look selfish,
you know,
because she,
cause she has to be honestly sitting there thinking like,
well wait a minute,
what if he really thought that this is enough?
You know,
how rude of it would it be for me to be giving you shit?
Oh,
wait a minute.
Wow.
I just had a flashback.
I just had a flash one time.
Oh my God.
One time.
One of my first girlfriends.
Right.
I grew up with all brothers.
I don't mean black people,
I mean that,
uh,
siblings and uh,
and I had a,
so I didn't know shit about women,
you know,
and a lot of you who are listening,
it's probably still think I don't.
So when he was my first girlfriend,
I went to buy her something for her birthday.
What the fuck did I get her?
I was on the road and I was like,
no.
So I was on the road.
It's already a comedian.
This wasn't my first Mike,
this is my second serious girlfriend.
I was like 25 years old,
24,
25 and that was in the mall and I bought her this shirt.
Was there a birthday?
And I swear to God,
I think it was one of those,
you know,
those polo style shirts.
I bought her one of those and it was like striped.
I got a two of them and I wrapped him up and she was all excited.
She was just complete fucking psycho that I was dating.
As I told you before,
you know what the deal is when somebody dating is psycho and you're sitting
there going,
why are they dating this fucking person?
You know why all psychos are good in bed.
At least everyone that I ever met,
not only the good in bed,
they're fucking unbelievable in bed.
All right?
So I'm sitting there like I,
you know,
I don't know why I didn't I just ask a woman,
just get help me out here.
But I basically bought or what I would have bought my older brother.
So,
and this is the thing,
I hadn't had a girlfriend a couple of fucking years,
uh,
you know,
just one of periods where I was just focusing on,
on becoming a comedian.
And I don't even think I was really even,
whoa.
I went through a fucking dry spell like an 18th month fucking not hooking up
nothing.
So this girl says,
psycho comes into my life.
So I buy,
are these two fucking izod looking shirts that,
you know,
a married father with three with three fucking kids would be pissed if he got
there.
And I gave it to this disco was fucking hot too,
right.
And I gave it to her and she's all excited and it professionally wrap.
That's the one thing I did.
So she's thinking it's going to be something nice.
And she goes and she fucking unwraps the stamp thing and uh,
she opened it up and she just like,
and I was standing up and I was so fucking nervous and she just goes like,
what?
She's like,
what,
what is this,
what you'd be bought me this,
this.
And she starts holding upon this and she's like,
this is stupid.
She kind of like throw it down.
I can't remember what the fuck she said.
All I remembered was by the end of it I was sitting and she was standing and she
was fucking like,
I was getting scolded like a child.
You're like your first girlfriend when your first relationship or whatever.
You just think of the dumb shit that you did.
It's like my second one,
but I'm such a moron.
I had to learn this shit over again.
I was just sitting there getting fucking scolded for like 10 minutes about this
awful fucking,
admittedly it was awful.
But what the fuck?
You know what kind of a fucking cunt would do that?
I don't have a date and I'm like fucking two months.
But she,
I sat there like this sad kid getting scolded and it was one of those things
where I w the only reason why I sat there was cause I was so embarrassed and I
didn't have a lot of experience with women and all I wanted to do,
I wanted to crawl out of there.
It felt like the way it felt the first time I bombed doing jokes,
that's how bad it felt.
And then as she got to the end of her 10 minute fucking tirade about how bad
this fucking gift was,
that's when I started getting my feet underneath me where finally the shame and
the embarrassment had gone away because she just gave me shit for so long that I
was actually able to regroup and I was like,
wait a minute.
I don't even think I yelled at her.
I just remembered that switch in my head just went,
you know what?
Fuck this person next.
And uh,
later on that night she actually called me up and apologize.
It's just like,
yeah,
listen.
Um,
I,
I probably shouldn't have said that and I was totally passive aggressive.
No,
no,
it's fine.
No,
it's cool.
You know,
you know back then when you don't know how to get out of a relationship,
I know it's too,
that's cool.
So you want to come see me tonight?
Oh,
actually I got,
oh whoa.
I got up,
fixed the toilet,
uh,
fucking clean off the stove.
Uh,
my brother's coming to town and gave her like every fucking excuse and I,
uh,
okay.
I basically,
in a coward way,
just sort of back my way out of that.
Has that ever happened?
Oh No.
Wait.
I remember how I remember how I got out of it,
but I can't tell you cause it's fucking horrific and some stuff is just too
personal and I'm gonna leave you at that and they'll leave you fucking hanging.
Fuck you.
It's an hour in one minutes into this podcast,
right?
It.
Was this one loud enough for you?
I hope it was.
Now people are going to say it was too fucking loud.
So that's the podcast for this week everybody.
I am a,
I am comfortable with my new hour.
It is official.
I got this fucking thing down and I'm going to go up to San Francisco and I am
going to rake whoever the fuck shows up with my goddamn comedy.
That's how it's going down.
I got to show their Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
and Sunday.
Let me double check.
Make sure it's not Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
I know it's Friday,
Saturday,
Sunday.
My also doing the Thursday.
Let's see the second,
third,
fourth,
fifth.
That's four days.
Yeah.
Thursday through Sunday.
COBB's comedy club and I'm gonna tell you right now,
for years the people of San Francisco are going to be talking about the shit
jokes that I'm going to be performing this weekend.
These are going to,
these are instant classic Shit Jokes and Dick Jokes that you need to come out
and see a,
there's not a lot of tickets left everybody.
I have no idea how many tickets I sold.
I'm just doing that late night TV bullshit that they do.
We only got five left,
so come on down.
Don't be a fucking pussy.
Come on down.
I'm doing that DVD signing at some borders bookstore.
He wanted me to come down.
I'll fucking signed a DVD.
Assign your Teddy's.
I don't give a fuck.
I could give a shit.
Come on down.
I'll sign something.
I got pen.
I've got a pen and Anna and a fucking a and a sharpie.
Ready to go.
All right,
that's it.
That's a podcast for this week.
In two weeks I'm going to be at the Improv in Bray,
California.
So for all you people out here asking me when the fuck I'm going to be in Bray
California,
there you go.
December 16th,
17th 18th and 19th.
Then I'm all my Christmas break where I stare at my bulls.
Um,
and then um,
I'm doing the Gada in Atlantic City and uh,
we,
we sold out that show in 30 hours.
Hopefully they're going to add a second show would be great if you guys called
up and asked them to add a second show.
And then they could,
but that show is a,
that's the Miami heat comedy show is homme branding it.
It's Jim Norton,
Jim Breuer,
Dave Attell,
and myself.
How the fuck do you not add a second show?
How do you as a comedy fan not call up the board God are right now and be like,
dude,
what the fuck?
Add a second show,
or I'm coming down there and I'm taking my dick out and I'm running through your
fucking casino.
Uh,
all right.
That's it.
I've really overstayed my welcome.
That's a podcast for this week.
You guys have yourselves a great week.
Don't take any shit.
And uh,
that's it.
Go Fuck Yourself.
[inaudible]
yes.